so stick around to the variant so we can
give you the PDF of where you rank as a
nice guy because the complete opposite
of being a nice guy it's what it's mean
unpleasant [ __ ] pestering many words
we can use for it but what does it mean
to be a nice guy and why does it suck to
be a nice guy I mean let's see what's
wrong with that right I want to be a
nice guy you want to be a nice guy
here's the reality of it and it's one
thing that nice guys don't do and this
applies to everything in life but nice
guys when you stay nice in everything
you do you simply miss a lot of
opportunities whether it's dating
whether it's career whether it's
Investments whether it's a lot of things
just because you're worried about
something you do could potentially
offend somebody so let's look at this
pendulum here together
foreign
so on the far left on the screen that
you're looking at you see the nice guy
on the far right it shows pestering the
next level after nice is somebody who is
timid right they're in a room they have
thoughts they want to do things in their
minds they're role-playing that a
conversation they're having with
somebody or they're wanting to present
something or wanting to say something
but they don't because they're timid in
their mind they said it in their mind
they said what the other person said but
what happens in their mind doesn't play
out in real life so timid it's gonna be
very hard to win in business and in life
if you're going to be timid constantly
the next one is somebody who's very
confident there's a lot of confident
people who are nice they're not insecure
they don't second guess themselves
they're just quiet and they're confident
but they don't do one thing and you're
ready they don't ask they simply don't
ask even though they're confident even
though they may be the sharpest cat in
the room even though they may have a lot
to offer but they're just confidently
quiet even though they're confidently
quiet they're missing out on a lot of
different opportunities then right in
the middle is somebody that's very
rational you here's how they think to
themselves if I were to ask the question
they're probably going to say this so
there's no point in me asking a question
because I already know what the answer
to the question is going to be I'm not
going to be asking the question they're
probably not going to be doing business
with us because rationally this doesn't
make any sense to ask versus you don't
know you're assuming you don't know if
they're going to say yes to your product
you don't know if she's going to say yes
to going out with you you don't know any
of that the only way you know is if you
do what is if you ask now we're going
into the the space where you're going to
have more opportunities but also you
know what comes with more opportunities
also more rejections so the next level
is somebody that's assertive now you're
going into good space assertive is
somebody that's very comfortable
asserting themselves in a conversation
asserting themselves in an event to be
talking to people hi I'm John I like
your suit what's your name what do you
do for a living are you from here where
are you from oh wow how do you know
Billy with the party that he put
together how do you know Mary how far
you go back with Mary very interesting
what do you do for business you're
assertive you're able to have those
types of conversations right when you're
being assertive the next next one after
assertive is you're able to challenge
and push back a little bit so now what
does it mean to challenge and push back
you know like for example imagine you're
sitting at a table and there's eight
people talking dirt and everyone's
talking about the fact that who's the
greatest basketball player of all time
oh who's the greatest president of all
time well why did what happened to covet
here oh the debate on faith religion
business politics sports cars what's the
fastest car in the world what's the best
exotic car in the world and I think it's
a Ferrari I think it's a Lambo I think
it's a dish and you could sit there and
be rational not say anything but
somebody could say the following you
know what John I understand where you're
going but I have to push back let me
explain to you why it depends if you
like a Lambo most buyers of Lamborghini
most buyers are Ferrari are this and
then the other person can come back and
say yeah I understand what you're saying
I know the history but I'm telling you
Aston Martin is this so forget about the
thing it's done you push back a little
bit everybody goes in their cars they
leave this party everyone's having a
cigar they're having a drink or whatever
it may be when they go in the car
those 10 people in the car are going to
say what do you think about
what he said when he pushed back and he
said ask to Martin I disagree with them
he actually has a good point but they're
talking about you
because you challenge and you push back
now you're a topic of discussion that's
the benefit of being assertive and
challenging and pushing back instead of
being timid or confident or quiet or
rational or nice you're missing out on
many opportunities because those 10
people when they go to the next party
you know what everyone was going to ask
is such and such going to be there oh
yeah he's coming I can't wait to see him
again oh hey what's up Aston Martin guy
no matter what they remember you you're
memorable right if you're on this side
now can you go past uh challenging and
pushback and uh be a little bit too much
yes that's when you go into the
pestering mode and when you go into the
pestering mode now you're annoying uh
now you're a little too much now people
don't want to be around people that
pester right there's a level that you go
a little bit too much where you're
overly doing it like I'll do some
business meetings and some people sit
now I'm like oh my God I understand how
much money this person's spending I
don't want his money because he's
pestering he's distracting the audience
but I love this other guy assertive he
is I love this guy that he pushes back
and says I disagree I would have hired
this person because that creates for
dialogue this person just trying to get
attention they need to call their mom
and go to a different event these people
need to be in the event because they
make the meeting better and they make
everybody smarter so
mister or Mrs nice person that you are I
got a challenge for you maybe start
asking some questions maybe start kind
of pushing back a little bit and you'll
find yourself finding more newer
opportunities people are going to push
back you may have some more rejections
but some tells me you're going to enter
a whole new world of opportunities that
you didn't have before just being a nice
guy so now look whether you're a nice
guy and you're trying to be a little bit
more assertive or you're the [ __ ] and
you're trying to be less of an [ __ ]
you want to be more assertive side
regardless if you're consuming this
content you have to get the new
entertainment ads that just came out
these are handmade new limited edition
ones on the site says future looks right
on the bottom of the lid says future
looks bright the Italian logo in there
somebody from MIchigan the other day
ordered one hat first then they ordered
three for all the three colors they wore
it at work they ordered 58 the next day
because they wanted all of their
employees to have these if you haven't
bought these let me make a prediction
when these sell out and we sell the new
numbered ones you wish you would have
bought these when we had limited
supplies if you haven't yet ordered
these click on the link over here to be
able to order the hats and if you enjoy
the content today you want the PDF for
free description newsletter will send a
PDF over your way take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]